let's go
all right jacob we're here
luke and jake here at the outdoor boys
youtube channel and today we're in
the uinta mountains of utah and we
are going to kayak out to that island
where we're gonna be
fishing catching crawfish and camping
[Music]
[Applause]
hey jake are you ready for an adventure
yeah yeah let's do it
i love fishing and camping on the shores
of the lake but often there's a lot of
rules
and regulations forbidding that anywhere
where you have a lot of people there's
going to be a lot of rules
so we're going to be a little creative
and kayak out there to that abandoned
island
so we can have the whole place to
ourselves and fish and camp
all night long
this water is crystal clear
look at that
we're here
look at this this sure is pretty
you wouldn't believe it in the high
mountain lakes of utah but there are
some huge
crawfish here and we're going to try to
get a bunch for dinner
go back to the car get our crawfish
traps bait them up and uh we're going to
start fishing
all right now we gotta get all the way
back to the car
go ahead and drop them
first thing we're going to do today is
set out our crawfish traps and i've got
these baby carp here and we're going to
chop those up and use those as bait
we also have some chicken legs as bait
these crawfish traps are called pillow
traps and i made them myself
from a bit of chicken wire just a few
days ago they're really simple to make
they take about four minutes a piece and
all you need is some chicken wire
some wire cutters zip ties strings and a
bottle you just make a tube out of the
chicken wire then you pinch the ends
shut
and the corners you push them inward so
they make kind of like these funnels
with lots of room here
and you do that on all three corners
except for this one
so the crawfish can come in either which
way but they have a hard time getting
out
all but this way then you put the string
on near the middle but closest
the open corner so that when you pick it
up the open corner is facing up
but you just go and take and drop a
piece of fish down in there and we are
ready
to fish
[Music]
okay all right we got each trap set with
a piece of chicken and a piece of carp
we're gonna go see if we can't catch
some crawfish
let's cruise around and see if we can
find a spot with lots of crawfish
maybe we'll
everything loves to eat crawfish so they
tend to hide in the rocks during the
daytime
and come out at night so uh we'll just
kind of see what happens but
we should be able to see them in the
rocks
oh there's one see him see he's oh
there's a bunch of them right there
i can see a bunch of big ones swimming
around running away from us
okay
i'd really like to catch some trout in
here they have some very nice ones
i just saw a couple of suckers about
that big
stock
you just kind of throw them in the boat
all yeah there you go
you ready jake yeah
you know throw it throw it out there
there you go
why don't you go and drop it right there
throw the bottle in the water there you
go all right we got all the crawfish
traps set
and some of them are just covered in
crawfish already and
i think we're gonna catch a lot of
crawfish
all right bud hop on out
here at this reservoir we're at 7 600
feet which means you can get sunburned
so easily so that's why we're wearing
our neck gators and we've got
50 spf sunscreen on you can get burned
really easy at this elevation it also
means it gets
much colder at night much quicker it's
supposed to be a low of 31 degrees
so even though it's the middle of summer
in a desert
i've got a three season tent here and
i've got a 20 degree bag for me
and a 15 degree back for jacob it's just
weird got our sleeping bags in here
uh-oh i think i pitched the tent on top
of my cooking pot
yep that's right this is the nemo
dragonfly three-person tent
it's very light it's a great backpacking
tent it's very warm
holds up pretty well in bad weather but
it is
very tight if you were to fit three
adults in here you would be
literally sleeping you know shoulder to
shoulder
you know you'd be touching each other
it's a little tight for me and two of my
boys
but it's perfect for me and one other
kid
hey you see what i mean about space
works really well for
one adult one kid or maybe even an adult
and two kids
jake you want to fish yeah all right you
got the final arms
yeah all right come come over here yeah
i'm gonna put it right here this right
here is the diawa liberty club
short swing surf rod it's from japan
it's the 2270 got a daiwa tatula reel on
it
and this thing is so light if you drop
it in the water
with the reel on it it'll actually float
and i can put it in my checked bag so
easy
i use them for catfish and carp and
trout love them
so this reservoir has rainbow trout
cutthroat trout
coconut salmon uh suckers maybe some
catfish you just don't know what you're
gonna catch but everything loves to eat
earthworms so i'm gonna throw uh one rod
out with some earthworms on a bottom rig
i'm gonna throw another one out
uh under a float and we're gonna see
what happens
so i got my rod set up in these bite
alarms anything comes and hits it
makes a nice loud beep so me and jay can
mess around with our stuff if a fish
comes along and bites we're gonna hear
it
well i've got a little boy who is
hounding me to go check
the crawfish traps isn't that right
buddy you want to go check the crawfish
traps
they've only been soaking for about an
hour but it'll give us a good idea of
which locations they're producing and
which ones aren't
oh we got a fish we got a fish
we got him we got him we got our fish
you want to reel in him
yeah okay reel him in
oh did you pop off oh it popped off
what was it i have a really weird bait
set up here
i've got a carp rig with a fake piece of
corn on a hair rig
what i did is i took some of this uh
trout bait here ball of it around the
corn
like that then i put an earthworm on the
actual hook like that
okay pull it up grab that bottle
[Music]
pull the string up high five fast pull
it up pull up oh i see him
i see him see pull up the traps look at
the trims
we have some look at this look at it
some nice ones too
pull it up all right look at this here
we go
what you do is grab the bottle and you
got to
pull it up quickly you pull them up
throw it over there right there all
right
another crawfish
all right that's a few of them
i'll do a little snack
here do you see them
almost yeah they're so armored look at
this
yeah look at these hey see if you grab
them behind the shoulders they can't
pinch you
unless of course you're doing a crawfish
fight
hey look at this he's pinched you they
go see
he's pinched your life jacket see that's
why you always wear a life jacket while
crawfishing
here i got it you you don't mind picking
them up do you
yeah throw them in there there you go
there we go
all right you ready to eat some crawfish
yeah okay you wanna show you how you eat
them
yeah grab their tail and you just
pull like that you grab the the tail fin
and you pull it straight out if you pull
the fin straight back sometimes you can
pull the poop out
and then you pop the shell on the side
anything that's crunchy you just remove
now there you go a little bit of tail
meat
jake you want to try that yeah
you can bust the claws off bust the
thumb off squish the claw
we need a little bit of clobby you're
really hardcore
you suck the mustard out of the head
good so you bet you're wondering how on
earth
are there crawfish at 7 000 feet in the
rocky mountains of utah
well they were introduced and they are
not a native species
and there's absolutely tons of them and
very few people around here eat them
so there's no bag limit and almost zero
regulations on them you just get a
fishing license and you can go to town
on crawfish
that's the freshest seafood you'll find
in utah
there's so many crawfish here because of
another non-native species the
landlocked salmon called the kokanee
salmon it's basically a red salmon or a
sockeye salmon
that's land locked and every year the
kokanees go up into the rivers
spawn and die and their bodies get
flushed into the reservoir
and the crawfish go crazy on them you
wanna you want to eat the corns
that's their poop
inside we're eating their butts well
this ain't my first rodeo introducing
small
kids to crawfish they generally love
playing with them but don't eat a ton of
them
so i have some backup dinner ready for
jacob
okay try that out see what you see if
you like it
in these high altitude dry environments
you get dehydrated
so quickly and you've just gotta keep
drinking water and little kids are
really bad at that they just won't force
themselves to drink when they're not
feeling like it
a little powdered drink mix will go a
long way to keeping kids drinking water
and keeping them hydrated
there you go a little cup for you
i think count dracula here needs a wet
wipe
oh
[Music]
okay i'd like to catch a ton of crawfish
on this trip so what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna let the trap soak
until right about bedtime then we're
going to go out in the kayak and pull
the traps
rebate them throw them out and uh
hopefully tomorrow morning we're going
to have a ton
of crawfish but we got a couple hours
before bedtime so i think
me and jake should digest in the tent
and watch some cartoons
sit down and we'll take your boots off
so you don't get your boots on the
on the sleeping bags you're an earthworm
yeah one thing i do love about this tent
it has
one two three four five
pouches to put stuff if you're gonna
have a small tent you better have a lot
of storage space
oh we got a fish
oh look at this what a
lovely trout look at that
that is a nice healthy fish i think we
need to have some trout with our
crawfish
huh that is a nice fish look at that
well that's awesome i want to go catch
some more of those we're going to eat
the truck tomorrow and i want to keep it
alive
until then so i grabbed one of my
crawfish traps to put the
trout inside it and uh man look at this
we are loaded so i'm just gonna take the
trap
so there we go
oh there you go
that should work there's a fish a fish
oh look at it oh look at that beautiful
sucker
oh you put up a better fight than that
rainbow
what a beautiful fish but uh i ain't
gonna eat them so
let's
oh that was awesome camping with jacob
on a beautiful day
kayaking catching crawfish catching fish
it's nice all right the sun's almost set
we're gonna go pull all of our crawfish
traps and rebait them and
see what we got
oh yeah we got some a few we got a few
in there
uh five five
throw back in the fish
oh look at this there's even one on the
string
only one
we pulled six traps we baited them and
the sun's about to set so
we're gonna head back to camp and uh get
ready for the night
oh yeah look at that
got a good pile of crawfish there yeah
crawfish are supposed to be more active
at night so
who knows how many we'll have come
tomorrow morning
i accidentally ran over this with the
kayak and the trout got out
all right buddy hop into your bed okay
oh i remember when i bought these
jammies for nathan when we went to spain
i got jacob in a big agnes little red 15
degree
bag and i'm in a western mountaineering
uh 20 degree
down bag it's supposed to be in the 30s
tonight so
we'll see how we do but i think we'll be
we'll be in pretty good shape
he's so scary i'm a human
oh thank goodness
keep you warm tonight all right
lay down try to get some sleep okay
well jacob's asleep and i heard some
fish jumping so i freshened up the rods
and
uh i'm just gonna sit here and mess
around on my phone a little bit
maybe we'll catch something before i
need to call it a night but man this has
just been a
fabulous fabulous camping trip well i'll
tell you what guys it is no joke cold
right now and it is getting
colder i am using every bit of this
sleeping bag
and i'm considering putting on some hand
warmers or a fleece
it's cold we'll see we'll see how it
goes
oh i just realized if i hook a fish i'm
going to have to get out of my sleeping
bag
i just had another fish on and lost it
but it's uh
time to go to bed so i'm gonna reel it
in and uh get snuggled in my bag
it's so cold out here
oh good morning it is a beautiful
beautiful day jacob's still snoozing
away
it got cold last night but we were okay
ah worked out all right i'm just gonna
go ahead and get the fishing rods back
in and
just kind of take it easy and when jacob
gets up i'll make some breakfast
and then we're gonna pull those crawfish
traps
see what we got after they've sat out
all night long
i can hear little man starting to stir
in the tent
hey good morning jake you sleep well
last night
you stay warm good
what would you rather do first eat
breakfast
or check the crawfish traps
i thought i knew the answer to that
going to go get crawfish in our jammies
how cool is that
let's see about this one just two
oh look how many there are in here
holy mackerel
oh man there was like 20 in that one
i'm using this one-inch mesh chicken
wire so any of the small crawfish they
just jump out as soon as you start
pulling the trap because they can go in
and out of the trap really easy
so you end up with only the keepers
there we go he did pretty good bud
this one was trying to get away but he's
all tangled up oh this one was pretty
good
oh i think we tapped him out pretty good
yesterday
most the traps didn't do very well this
morning but two of them i'd set off in
slightly different locations
you know just 20 30 feet away
and those ones did real well so you know
lesson learned there
you got a pretty good amount of them
though beautiful and calm today exactly
what we need
i don't want to be kayaking with all of
our gear and jacob
when it's rough
well there we go that's that's not bad
i mean that's a meal right there some
nice ones
you want breakfast how about blueberry
granola you okay with that
home
well there we go we've got that kayak
right up to its max
weight capacity luckily it's glassy
smooth out there
and uh it's a right on top kayak so it
can't swamp but
we'll see what happens well i called my
wife and my in-laws to tell them that we
got some crawfish etouffee coming their
way
and all of them gave me a resounding no
thank you
so we're gonna let all the crawfish go
those are cool what a neat place but uh
where'd he go home and go see mama
i'm sorry buddy you okay yeah
okay well i'm gonna do it again but i'm
gonna
try again but this time daddy's gonna be
more
dad careful i'm going
see was that better
if you're soggy and you know it clap
your hands
okay is it funny that daddy wet his
pants
yeah yeah it is no
oh where that's it we're on the bottom
here i'll get out
there you go bud jake did you have a fun
time yeah
even though i dumped you in the water
well listen guys i hope you enjoyed this
video as much as we enjoyed this
adventure
please check out more videos from the
outdoor boys youtube channel check out
our playlist we have
camping adventure playlists travel
playlists
lots of great videos on there and don't
forget to check out my other channel for
more fishing videos the catfishing carp
youtube channel
between the outdoor boys and the
catfishing carp i have over 850
videos so lots of stuff to check out
but don't forget to click subscribe we
put out new videos
every saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
saturday morning
and hit that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching